you
[Music]
you know in the last few years actually
I've been kind of slowly getting
obsessed with this particular topic of
smart cities it was this accidental that
cannot started into this but I think
it's kind of turning out to be a very
interesting I think a rich space for a
lot of interesting research problems
which is what we are interested in but
also an opportunity to really shape how
these things will get implemented in
India right now so so I'll just kind of
try to present a kind of coherent story
on what we could do as technologists for
enabling really kind of futuristic smart
city solutions in India so and really
one of the main things which we have
been kind of trying to make a case for
is like an open stack which will really
allow for rich set of applications to
develop and emerge in the future so to
motivate this what I'll do is I'll kind
of go a little bit in in detail into
this recent RFP which has been put out
by the city of Agra which I'm sure
dipping out here will be able to kind of
tell you in much greater detail of many
other aspects of this RFP and we'll just
focus on the technology related aspects
of this particular RFP and I presume
that this this is a kind of a
prototypical RFP for a smart city which
is kind of similar to a lot of the other
what the other cities are doing or want
to be done and if you see out here one
of the key elements out here is this
integrated control and command center so
clearly they want like visibility as to
the overall operations of the city and
there are a number of components which
kind of plug into this command and
control center transportation
intelligent traffic management system
solid waste management surveillance
interactions with the citizens of the
city being able to communicate through
digital signage and so on so these are
all the various kind of components which
they would like to kind of have executed
in the the RFP which they have given up
given up so what we thought was let us
go into this RFP a little bit more
detail to understand from a technology
perspective what are the kind of key
elements which will need to be supported
so so the RFP also kind of says that you
need to have a layered approach and this
is kind of also common sense in some
sense especially with all the sensors
being deployed like cameras etc they
advocate having these multiple layers
out here sensor layer a communication
layer data layer an application layer
and what I would like to focus on as we
go forward in this talk is essentially
this layer the data layer which I
believe is like the core fundamental
layer which we really need to make sure
it's designed and constructed well
because it will really enable all kinds
of interesting things to happen in the
top once if that is done well so so if
you look at this the the traffic
adaptive traffic management system what
they would really like to do is to be
able to kind of manage the traffic in a
reactive you know smart way for example
they want to be able to control the
traffic signals optimally so that you
know it can change as required based on
the duration on the time of the day and
the traffic conditions
you know I guess this is a big deal in
India VIP vehicles so they want to be
able to you know automatically create
these corridors for VIP vehicles as the
less emergency and police vehicles they
would like to actually have incident
messaging being done in real time and
also they are little forward-looking in
the sense that they're saying let us
collect this data of all the traffic
make it available so that it can be used
for further analysis and improvement of
the road networks so if you look at the
implication on the data layer this
real-time Ness is kind of important
which emerges because you want to
quickly be able to connect to various
things also you want to be able to of
course it's not immediately apparent
from here but if you look at the error
Queen detail it's also apparent that you
want to be able to ingest data from a
diversity of sources you know cameras
crowdsource
you know police database systems etc
similarly you want to make the data
available to a diversity of applications
and it's not just this adaptive traffic
management system application but maybe
other applications they have these then
yeah that is a very good point and I
don't have an answer to that I mean if
you don't have enough capacity of the
road I mean there's not much you can do
you know in terms of that but hopefully
you can at least do some demand response
type thing you know you can stagger how
people you know titles kind of even out
the capacity by you know it's creating
incentive schemes and so on you know the
so that is one view is that why do all
this when we can't even make a proper
footpath you know you go we're not even
able to walk properly and we want to fly
you know but maybe we kind of bypass
this you know like what we did you know
with wireless you know we're directly
going to smartphone you know bypassing
the the intermediate layers so the other
thing is that I think one of the things
also which is embedded in the RFP turns
out is that you know this just making
the information available hope
we will allow citizens to kind of say
look what the heck are you doing you
know are you doing a job you know why
haven't you fixed this and so on so that
also hopefully there'll be some positive
which comes out of just making the data
available right yes yeah yeah so yeah
auger I don't think as it said anything
about bike bicycles okay so you know you
have to also get the appropriate
insurance yeah there are a lot of
interesting okay I said so for example
I'll point out something funny out here
so intelligent traffic and CC turbulence
so traffic comes again in two different
places adapt to traffic as well as as
part of this but I'm just kind of
reporting what they have said out there
here they really want to have the system
so put the police so this for the point
of view of the police's perspective you
know they want to be able to traffic
police be able to give fines you know do
traffic management monitor suspicious
people vital places video analytics
right so they want to be able to detect
no helmet whether someone is smoking in
the car this is funny wrong-way driving
detection so they want that
I don't know why they would like to
actually also detective people have long
hair short so this is kind of
interesting they would like to have
video coming from you know ad-hoc video
sources you know you just set up a video
network and then data should come from
there or variable like police is wearing
a video camera data should be coming
from there and so on and then of course
they want this to on top of the secure
communications so what this implies is
for the data layer you need to support
in to end security and also diversity of
video sources mobile variable ad hoc
type sources and you need to really
support a diversity of analytics which
might not be doable right now see the
point is some of this you know how long
a shorter it might take time to evolve
that but in the future you will have
more requirements for analytics and then
of course strong authorization and
authentication solid way
management you know they have this
probably true for most of the cities
they don't know what is going on you
know are people actually collecting the
ways they're supposed to are the
disposing of properly and so on so you
just need more visibility by putting
sensors to track vehicles monitor the
grease collection sites manage the roots
of this trucks etcetera man look at the
handover from one small truck to the
bigger truck you know what is going on
things like that and really increase
automation again out here diversity data
ingestion from a diversity of sources
followed by video analytics and they
also want video analytics they want to
see what is happening in the monitoring
you know the waste disposal sites are
things being done properly or not and
they would like all of this to be
reported summary to be reported to the
integrated command and control center
GIS is a big deal for this I guess most
of the smart city rfp's where they would
like to use this for better the venue
management and planning and urban
development and maintenance of public
places and so on and they would like
this to get integrated with other smart
solutions lighting surveillance so GIS
is important requirement for the data
layer being able to provide GIS data and
spaced it I'll come to this what I mean
by this little later in the talk so that
you can do a correlation analysis of
data from all these different sensors in
the context of yes
air quality noise light and being able
to report that through messaging
displays is something they would like
and they would also want these to be
tamper proof and so this is where you
know they were you know it's kinda
interesting some of these requirements
are coming up in the specific components
but their general you know they cannot
cut across the entire implementation of
smart cities so secure onboarding of
devices is important so that you can
trust the device which is sending the
data and detectives with the trust is
broken you would like to kind of know
how healthy these devices are and then
really again coming back to this
exchanging data between sensors and
other applications
I guess they want to kind of measure the
amount of noise decibel levels in these
places just monitor that I guess and you
could I guess if you had these
microphones you could also do some
analytics with that in you know in
conjunction with the video though they
are not asking for it but you could do
some interesting things with that I
guess yeah I don't know I'm not aware of
I'm sure there are certain laws said I
don't know I mean yeah I don't know
actually see it's like the air quality
right I mean there are certain safe air
quality levels to be maintained but you
know we are kind of not really
maintaining that so probably the same
happens with this noise touch okay I see
yeah so it's a Taj Mahal okay so that is
driving some of these requirements okay
yeah I guess once you start having data
see that is the thing is that maybe you
can kind of use that to drive some
actions policy actions after that around
that so for example this kind of data
would also be useful to correlate with
the health implications or the people
living in those areas right so we don't
have data but once we start having this
kind of data those kind of studies can
also be done and then we could inform
the the city could kind of do the
appropriate things in terms of yeah for
noise noise noise I don't know but I do
know that maybe the same people because
air quality related studies some of the
doctors in some of these hospitals are
interested and kind of doing that kind
of study along with some scientists in
Iasi so I guess noise is kind of related
so probably they would also be
interested in that yeah so st. John's is
something which is
the air quality for example the study
which the ISE scientist did along with
some of his colleagues from hospital was
to look at the asthma levels of children
in a school you know before and after
some change in the traffic you know
routing and there was a noticeable
change in the asthma levels when of
course they changed some you know
traffic you know since the departs for
some of these heavy vehicles and over a
six-month period that my father was
actually went up and then it came down
when you know the old routing was
established so clearly you know there is
a major connection out that did the
health and even the educational outcomes
you know too much noise might also
prevent children from focusing and so on
so they want this latency of 15
milliseconds roundtrip you know which I
don't know I think it might be kind of
aggressive with certain jitter specs and
loss effects and so on for the
communication network and authentication
of devices through these certificates
and being able to look at the health of
all these things so I think the message
here is that real timeless is important
whether one can meet these specs or not
is a different issue but I think that
makes sense you know there is a
ambulance coming in you want to kind of
notify and change the signals and so on
I think it's Price Waterhouse initial
develop EDB they yeah exactly yeah so it
could also be that certain big
corporates also help these packs so that
their equipments will meet these
standards I don't know how this works
but that is the point I can I want to
make is that if you look at these RFPs
the you know in some sense this is that
the let this is the level at which the
specs are written and it's already like
300 phase document you know just this
technical stuff and then from there to
derive even more detail specs you know
that's where what I want to make a case
is that we really need to get down to
those details you know of being able to
properly get to the next level of
technical specifications of each of
these yeah that's why I cannot put this
up list so that you know it comes out
this is the kind of spec which is there
right now in the RFP this is what they
are asking for that sorry yeah
see they have just fact that it needs to
be in - and latency round-trip latency
is 15 millisecond now I presume it is
probably they had these applications
like the signaling traffic light control
creating a green corridor when a VIP
vehicle comes or emergency vehicle comes
so maybe that is driving this particular
respect and yeah 50 millisecond from the
time the sensor says look I'm my
emergency vehicle I'm here to going and
changing the probably the traffic light
to set the color green corridor up in
that local space I'm kind of speculating
that is what is driving one possible
example use case for the screen of
respect so it from the sensor it goes
through the communication network it
doesn't go through the app so here they
are not even mentioning anything about
the app because there is a complete
application stack through which it goes
and comes back everything has to be
within 50 minutes and the jitter of two
percent of 7.5 millisecond that is
details two percent of the one way
latency probably for video or something
I don't know where that is coming from
and what is the motivation for that yeah
so this is the the so the the integrated
command and control is like the key
piece of this smart cities right and
really they have aspiration to break the
silos between departments you know they
want a single window visibility of all
that is going on in the city and they
want to have this integrated operations
platform which is like the core of that
which will expose data through API
support distributed deployment of
workflow stream analytics correlate
handle multiple data stream developer
support vendor agnostic software
development kits api's security ice and
they want to have analytics for
loitering detection abandoned objects
that stretch it I'm kind of bringing
these things up because this kind of how
the RFPs are also written you know in
sense these are the consultants who come
in and write these rfp's
there are some elements which are
captured which are what is the city's
one plus there are certain other
additional things which are put in here
see this is what they have written in
one of those places so what we want to
actually be sees on this and we are
saying let's make this this let's try to
get this thing achieve this as a
OpenStack open API framework and now
this is the RFP which hasn't put it and
the normal course of operations what
will happen is that there will be one
master system integrator like Sterilite
or LNT or someone will put pull together
all the different vendors for
surveillance waste management etcetera
etcetera and probably each of the vendor
will have their own complete stack from
sensors all the way to the dashboarding
and then some other they will integrate
it into the there will be a single
command and control center where you'll
have all these little snippets of videos
running from each of these different
applications so it really is siloed in
some sense so that's probably what will
happen this is really nothing more
specified in terms of further levels
into specification in terms of
standardizing the framework for
exchanging data so that you can really
exchange data across different
applications devices and even cities in
some sense right you want to kind of go
to that level so also really there is no
support for an economy based on data
because that is kind of the recurrent
theme thing in any of these so that data
is the recurrent thing so you have to
figure out how to make money off data so
there is really no support for that so
that is a little bit future thinking we
need to do there's no mention of privacy
so that is you know now we now know that
that is one of the most important things
right now but there is really no mention
of privacy in these so what we really
need is kind of a platform which
standardizes the API is in the data
models so that it helps application
developers it should be targeted at
application developers instead of just
having end complete applications and
then it should really support AI type
solutions which are emerging and really
unleash the innovation and the precip
for new applications to develop
these applications yeah there are a lot
of I think already Pune has implemented
something and some of the some of the
cities have which a little bit early
have implemented that so you can have
vendors for example which will provide
your solutions for surveillance so
there's someone called video netic will
provide you that complete with the
cameras and VMS and all that parking I
guess a lot of players startups and so
on and some lighting management video a
think there is something which is which
is there in this the data empowerment
and privacy depe DPA I think right that
is something which has been yeah yeah I
think matey has adopted it so I think
those guidelines are supposed to be
that's what someone was involved with
that told me that you know that will be
legally binding so no because this
privacy thing is like a very recent
thing which is kind of brought to our
attention right I'll just come to that
next year so so now what we are saying
is that let us focus on the data layer
right and we really need a well-defined
data exchange layer and it needs to be
an open platform with open APs and data
models so that instead of the siloed it
gets replaced by this what I'm showing
is a hover glass model at the neck of
the hourglass is the key that is the
city it's a little verbose city data
exchange and edge analytics stack and
I'll tell you why a general takes is
important shortly so so this data
exchange stack what it does is it's the
intermediary between the
producers of data which is all these
sensors and the consumers of data all
the applications the sensors could be
Hardware sensors but it could also be
software senses other applications could
do further delay you know refinement of
data and produce alerts and messages and
so on and really this kind of an open
stack will enable very complex
applications in the future you know
emergency response we spice together
information from multiple diverse
sources and connect with multiple
different ways of connecting with
citizens crowd monitoring accident
detection as well as prediction in
preventing accidents so that is kind of
what we really need going forward and to
do a lot of these things you need to
integrate analytics across video and
other sources if you see currently video
is a complete separate beast by itself
you know video is separate everything
else is separate so we really need to
kind of integrate you know as
application developer you need to be
able to consume a video stream as well
as stream coming from other sensors
nearby and really this architecture is
you know this is something inspired by
other can have this is what they do for
other right this a course kernel you
identify which enables a whole set of
ecosystems to be built around it and if
we do it right we can have portability
across vendors for devices as well as
portability across cities application
development Bangalore should work on
surah it's attached so I think that is
what we should be aiming for as a
country not have all these cities
independently just doing their own
little thing and then you know I mean at
least this let's see if we can through
it correctly the smart city solutions
that is our hope
yeah
that is a good question so nothing
explicit has been mentioned in the RFP
at least I couldn't notice but certain
numbers have mentioned like for example
like you know for I think for
surveillance related application we know
that people want to store it for at
least 30 days or something I believe and
the video data the other sensor data is
really not much I guess compared to
video videos really the the beast in
some sense and they are saying that you
have the archive data to do further
analysis and you know help and so on but
it's not really been quantified I think
that that is the next level where one
has to be able to say okay you need this
much amount of storage to store these
kinds of data so for video it is there
because certain requirements require you
to store so many days worth of data but
see I think for for video from a
forensic perspective you know they
definitely want the raw data in fact you
don't you should not be touching the raw
data it should be as it is right and you
know but there could be a lot of other
cameras which are not really part of the
surveillance system you just put them
for those you know I guess it's up to
the how you implement those right I mean
you really care for this raw data coming
in nothing is happening like a waste
monitoring site you have a camera you
just want to know if someone is actually
people have showed up to work or not
maybe right I mean maybe that's the
alert you want so the raw data might not
be that useful there so I think that is
also kind of open in some sense
so that is okay so that is really why
the edge analytics comes in
in fact from maybe I just kind of say
why we need the edge analytics is
essentially for what you pointed out the
amount of video data is just too much to
stream to the cloud it has to be locally
stored locally consumed local is what so
local could be award maybe locality
again it depends on the kind of
investment and the city is able to put
in I I feel that it should be local at
the level of a word or a locality or a
campus or some such thing and then
that's kind of what I'll kind of discuss
in the next few slides so that you don't
really ship this huge amounts of data
all over the place it's just consumed
there and then that's why you need the
edge analytics also it's only the other
it's such a transcend so this data
exchange layer needs to have what are
the attributes for this right we need to
have very strong security handle
heterogeneous data across video and
other IOT data these are the key
functionality of supporting exchange of
data between various applications and
devices have a be a repository of data
models because just raw data by itself
is not useful what is the metadata about
the data and that is something else we
insisted on that every source of data
comes with metadata information so that
you know what it means support low
latency have API send SDKs and because
of the the need for local just for video
if it does not video it probably a
generalities might not be that useful
but maybe other than for latency reasons
but definitely video requires I think
fog / edge analytics and now what was
missing here we would like to also add
these three requirements that they
should be strong protection for privacy
so if someone is your you should know as
a citizen which all cameras or whatever
video feeds you appear in I mean that
would be nice to know and then you need
to have a marketplace to be able to buy
and sell data and of course support AI
type applications I'll kind of briefly
mentioned what what I mean by that
[Music]
yeah at least be able to know see
because if you take that forward maybe
you lock the data and that is yeah
I think those are all opportunities for
startups to offer services along those
lines you know that's what I think so
for example analytics is the service
right annotation as a service you know
all these are interesting opportunities
to think of coming up with solutions of
those and that's where these kinds of
data stacks which are very open will
support those kinds of new kinds of
services to come up so this is the this
is the stack basically what we are
saying and
you know it's not very different from
what any of these IOT type stacks look
like except of the you know there are
few things out here of course you have
the brokers for streaming messages and
alerts and so on which is kind of an
archive being able to access these
archived versions of these messages also
support for real-time messaging but the
video and audio the media brokers and
data base is also part of the stack so
that you access this and basically a
directory of data resources out here
which is a catalog which has all the
meta information al can I give an
example of how that might look like
support for certain contexts because if
you want to really interpret the data
coming in you need to know what is the
context so that you can do your
inferences and so on so that is kind of
what I meant by AI support and a
specific example I'll just talk about
the spaces then which is also very
important I guess in the context of
video and a general ethics is that you
need to be able to support running of
analytics I'm not you know this support
to run analytics at the fog and edge
edge layer and then a kind of a
framework for authentication
authorization provisioning etcetera as
part of this so this is basically the
stack and we want to kind of and all
this is kind of expose as api's and each
of them runs as services or micro
services in some senses it's from an
implementation perspective so if you
look at from a deployment option you
have the stack at the center and you
know the currently the present what will
probably happen is that you already
might have applications running base
management is an application someone has
develop etcetera so with adapters you
kind of put data into the stack and the
command and control center will push
pull data off the stack in some sense
and also communicate through this so
this is kind of how probably the
immediate feature with legacy or ongoing
applications
you know things will work out but maybe
going forward you can have decouple the
data producing portion from the data
consumption portion even you know the
data producing portion is just done by a
bunch of companies consuming is done by
some other kind bunch of companies and
all of them work through the data
exchange stack in some sense so so what
you can see from the command and control
center is not just the data but also the
health of the devices and health of all
the things producing the leader that is
essentially the all the management
systems be a mass element management
system network management system they
also report the health of all these
different devices different things to
the command and control center if when
we think in terms of that is kind of the
software perspective and you look at the
hardware perspective what you will have
is a collection of gateways or IOT
gateways which are out there publicly
deployed possibly on street poles
because those are something which are
all over the city they have access to
power so you have these street poles
where each street pole has this IOT
gateway with a bunch of local acquired
connected sensors and actuators and
perhaps also ingesting data from nearby
sensors wirelessly and all these street
poles are connected through a van to the
local micro data center so this could be
at the level of a campus or a ward or
locality and this micro data center
actually has the van terminator network
switches and then compute and storage
services what of it
so this becomes the what is called the
fog load you know some people call it
the fog some people I mean there's
different terminologies but this is the
Micro data center sitting there you know
kind of serving a locality out here and
so we kind of expect this to be kind of
the hardware realization of the smart
city solutions and you know if you do it
that way you can kind of you know do it
in a modular fashion you know each
locality gets lit up in some sense or
iota fied and then you have all these
micro data centers which are then kind
of managed or visible as in a unified
way through your integrated command and
control center so this way you kind of
slowly light up different portions of
the city
under step-by-step basis and the
software itself you would want to of
course make it run in a distributed
fashion so what here I'm showing is that
the the core the API gateways and the
authentication etc is in some sense
unified and centralized but the the
stack itself the brokers etcetera run a
distributed fashion each in the local
micro data center so that way the whole
thing is actually distributed out here
so there are a few concepts which we
kind of want to kind of bring out out
here which are kind of I think
interesting and maybe some of them are a
little new in some sense so one is of
course the registry of data sources now
this is something which ocf is also and
their multiple approaches to our efforts
to try to come up with a schema a
standard framework for capturing the
meta data so we are looking at we looked
at what OC of dead and cannibal and we
are proposing something along those
lines where any IOT source or any data
source has a schema which has four
pieces of information there is some
static information there is some in
schema about the observation database
comes in schema but the control data
which goes to the device and then schema
for the configuration read and as an
example out here one of the elements is
the output of Lux sensor which is of
type number which is measuring the LED
output intensity units of Lux and it has
what we are also saying is that there is
an access modifier to kind of control
the privacy setting out here so you have
private data you have protected data
your public data private data is only
accessible to the owner of the data
whereas protected this data which is
available to someone who's authorized
and public is open to available to
everyone now this kind of schema
the idea is that any data source when it
gets registered in the system also has
to put in a schema which describes what
is the you know which kind of tells you
about the format of the data coming in
and then the system can validate the
pieces of actual data
which come in against the schema that is
what is shown out here on the right side
so as an example if you take a street
light which you know so this is the kind
of schema which is this a proposal
schema which we have kind of
experimenting with in our reference
implementation which gives you some meta
information do the static portion where
is the street light located who owns it
how do you access the data from the
street light which is what is the
subscription in point what is the API
endpoint for getting the archival data
and then the data from the street light
itself what are the different pieces of
data which come in essentially when is
like do the sampling instant which is
the temperature of the casing the power
consumption the ambient Lux etcetera and
then some meta information describing
each of those so this is the control
information that is how do you go and
change the brightness level for example
of the street light so the actual data
from the street light will of course be
you know these Jason type documents
keyword values which are adhering to
that particular schema or there so so
that is that that was the first thing is
that every piece of data has to have
this data model which is uploaded the
second is video itself right so now with
video you know what does it we would
like to also treat video as an IOT
element what does it really mean for
video to be an IOT anyway well we need
to have some metadata about the video
and metadata of the semantic content of
the video not just the framerate and the
solution and so on but what is inside
there some description that we add this
Lux sensor and the units are Lux is
there some other similar information we
can put maybe about the semantic content
or some associated information I'll give
you a simple example so okay so for
example the if I look out here someone
could do an analytics on this video and
give out this meta data stream which is
associated with the video stream which
tells me where are you know are there
any autos in this video sequence you
know how many diesel vehicles are there
actually the thing is these kinds of
analytics then help the consumer to work
all
the analytics data and not worry about
the raw data anymore or the encoded
video stream now you're working on the
derived information as you go forward
right and this will really enable
complex applications to be built where
you build on this kind of analytics and
it will also allow an analytics service
providers who develop very specific
analytics and offer them as an extreme
so this formatting is a little messed
about here so for example a simple use
cases let us say you have a mobile video
source like a drone and the drawer is
giving out the encoded video stream but
you would like to know what are the
geolocation as a time series so that
that is extra meta information because
if you had that maybe geolocation maybe
the posts of the drone you can do better
much more interesting inferences with
the video stream so it's just a simple
schema to describe that very similar to
the schema of the street light here I'm
just looking at the data portion of the
schema which is telling me that this is
the timestamp of the metadata this is
the you need to be able to refer into
the video stream what portion of the
video stream is this piece of metadata
actually matching to start and end
pointer of the video and then what is it
what is actual data coming is just a
latitude longitude in this particular
example saying that you know this
portion of the video frame this is the
geolocation so you have now a stream of
that's what this picture kind of tells
you you have the video stream which is
going flowing out here and you have this
metadata of the four corresponding to
the video stream which is flowing on the
side out here so if a label this piece
of this metadata stream each metadata
packet actually is referring to some
portion of the video and then contains
some information about that ministry so
if you so this is one thing so have this
metadata stream which can which is also
in the catalog so any consumer will know
ok what what is this you know derived
information available so you can build
some new applications on top of it and
secondly if you want to subscribe to the
stream the video stream itself you need
to have a way of just like you would
subscribe to a IOT data stream you need
to be able to subscribe to video streams
so you need to have
streaming servers you know be able to
access archived streams etc and the
corresponding metadata which comes in
out here so one of the things is that
video is a lot of the video especially
for this surveillance camera is of only
locals push spatiotemporal relevance no
one else outside really cares about it
so I'm just kind of highlighting here
kind of a problem at least which we are
thinking about is how do you create this
localized efficient video distribution
system for the local region so that so
this I think is you know where you have
node balancing you have caching of these
brokers etcetera done for example you're
stuck in a traffic junction or you are
stuck in the road and you can want to
know what is happening ahead right
you're just curious so with your city
app you are able to subscribe to a video
camera which is just ahead and you see
okay this is why there is a problem then
you know it's just kind of curious to
know so this kind of a local consumption
of video from a local source to be able
to support these kinds of things also
you know be able to kind of adapt the
qsr of the local network for example if
I have some incidents happening in the
local region you probably want to
allocate more bandwidth to the cameras
around that region maybe you want to
track a crowd as it's going going past
right so adaptive QoS for those things
so these are these are some of the I
would say interesting rnd problems
I'm not saying this will be part of the
stack which we are doing but these are
some interesting problems which can
about looking at as you go forward so
the the thing with the video is that you
want to kind of consume the video and
analyze the video locally right now of
course you do it at the the fog layer
because those are standard computer
servers but I guess with technologies
which you guys had developed in ms er
you can also push that to the edges out
here on the IOT gateways now the thing
is that this collective of the micro
data center and this IOT gateway in some
sense forms cloud you know I can I call
it the street cloud so you have to come
in Street cloud has this heterogeneous
computer sources
in the IOT gateways and more compute in
the compute service so you know so
basically you cannot want to locally
terminate the video booth for privacy
and bandwidth and you want to run this
analytics out here in this street log
and so how do you do that you know what
is the programming model to allow you to
kind of develop applications like this
in a general way and what kind of end
time is required to support that and I'm
kind of you know so so this is something
again I think is a interesting kind of
systems problem to kind of look at as we
go forward as an example we have been
looking at this you know how you could
take advantage and do this kind of
distributed video analytics right so
where you have a camera and you have
some compute at the pole right next to
the camera and then you have more
heavier-duty compute out in the Micro
data center so here what we have
explored is how you can do this
tracking locally and the object
detection out in the Micro data center
so this is some work we did last year
where the you have a multiple cameras
and then you have an object detector
detector running in the Micro data
center and the D frames are the frames
on which to do the object detection in
the data center whereas the T frames are
done locally and next to the camera to
do the tracking so the detector of
course runs is a much heavier duty
detector running on one of these neural
nets and locally you do the tracking etc
so there is some benefit to doing this
this will be reported last year but I
think more interesting question is how
do you when you write this because you
know the it's always a moving target the
amount of compute you have every year is
improving even in the edge node you can
do more and more compute so you can't
like hard partition your things saying
that what you couldn't do today maybe
two years from now you can do easily in
the X so how do we write these
applications and make it so that these
pieces are able to move around
easily and collectively they do the job
you want to so that I think is also very
interesting problem so there is this the
third concept which we cannot want to
articulate out here is concept of space
as an asset right the space regions then
this is something which actually Intel
has been kind of brought to our
attention out here who are also part of
our collaborators out here so this
particular region this particular
conference room is a space region which
should be there in the database because
if you have sensors out here for example
the smoke detectors you should be able
to pin it to this particular space
region which means this space region
needs to have a entity kind of a
presence in your database with a
specific ID so that you can tie to that
it can't just be the geolocation because
you can't the geolocation will not work
well inside so that is a kind of concept
where you have spaces articulated as
assets and and the thing is that for
example these spaces if you take this is
the map just outside around this
vicinity where you have your Microsoft
Building you have ITC gardenia etc etc
so I've just marked out three space
regions so there is this sr1 which is
this piece of road sr2 is your Microsoft
building sr3 is this another building
out here and these regions are have to
be captured somehow of course in the
database you will have sr1 as a region
which has a unique ID it is described by
the street segment owned by the city of
Bangalore admitted by BBMP etc similarly
you have associated information for
every regions but more importantly you
have a structure which connects these
face regions together seeing that sr1 is
adjacent to SR to SR 3 etc and SR 1 is
part of this bigger space region called
a road Raja Ram Mohan Roy gold and so on
now why is this kind of interesting
because you know you can kind of use
this structure to do build your
application for example suppose there is
an incident which happens in this sr1
which is the road segment just in front
of you right who are the people who need
to be informed about that suppose I want
to just build a general application
right without customizing doing it for
this particular so then we
then what you would do is you take that
you look at the network you know this
graph structure and Traverse that and
figure out who are all the affected
people who get notified about that
accident so and you know this kind of
this is the context what what I meant by
saying supporting AI services is that
you capture the context and this context
is most likely in the form of a graph
and it not just be context of the space
region it could also be context which is
related to this organizational structure
you know so the many things out here
which are useful which can be it's
probably it should be captured so I
think that the challenge here is to
populate the database with such kind of
information you know maybe automated way
perhaps semi automated ways so that you
have a rich database which you can now
start using to do more and more
interesting automated eaj type
applications so but at the minimum at
least what we are saying is let us start
with the space regions and make that
available as a database and this week
should be able to automatically create
analyzing the shape files and so so
finally the security privacy and
manageability and regarding privacy and
I will just briefly mention that there
is work which is going on in India stack
as part of privacy supporting privacy
and they have something called a consent
layer which they're proposing so one can
look at that and see how we can adopt it
but the idea is that there is a clear
ownership of data who owns data and the
data can only be used with the
permission of the owner of the data so
that is basically what you want to be
able to support out there and also it
will be good to be able to track if I
share data with you you don't share it
with someone else without my knowledge
right so you need to also have a
mechanism for doing that so I think
those all can be done now with this
modern encryption and you know public
key PKI technologies so so so what we
have done is this particular you know
these are
kind of concepts at various levels of
maturity some of it is actually work in
progress and we have actually been
working on implementing some of these
yes yeah so you know so basically every
every device in the system needs to in
some sense have similar to our you know
biometric Orton you know identification
every device needs to have an
identification which is somehow tied to
some kind of root of trust of some kind
and you know I think some of these
things in the enterprise level people
have already solutions for that the
question is are they you know like you
have these TPM you have this trust zones
etc the access to the data is you know
is this kind of you have to get access
to the data so everything so it's a
there is owner of the data in the case
it could be the city so if you want to
access those streams you need to have
relationship with the city to get access
to the data now if you do some bad
things in the data you know that could
happen but there is some very clear
shall we say audit trail as you have
taken the data it's recorded somewhere
right right yeah I guess yeah it's
possible I don't know I mean you know
Security's like a big topic and you know
there could be ways of hacking around
systems but the thing is that at least
the point is there is end-to-end
encryption with also strong
identification of devices and humans
right so there is the identity
management system in place and the data
is only given to authorized people
essentially the owner of the data
authorizes the use of the data so that
is the kind of framework we can put in
see the the right now it is at a very
high level you know for example they
will say use Explorer 5:09 certificates
you know that is the kind of the level
so that is where the next level of
detail as to what it should be
the you're right the the you know the
certificates are one way of implementing
security I agree with you so what we are
actually doing is that the the at high
level you you want encrypted
communication right that is a high level
scrap but how do you achieve that
interpret communication right so what we
want to actually propose now I you know
essentially what we are doing is just
come to that but there is a consortium
we are making where we are coming up
with a more detailed specification some
of it and the the security side is kind
of on the implementation probably it is
at the flavor of implementation use this
you know use yeah so that's what it is
yes so so there's a lot of POC work
which we are doing with these some of
these devices you are making
the concept smart poll which we are made
which has these cannot be said this is a
smart street light which is on this poll
and there is a gateway out here which
has of course a PI Raspberry Pi on that
then we have a network of these poles
and this is the just an example
application where very toy a plication
where you could use video data have
analytics run off the video data and
then do something to manage your
streetlights so where you are kind of
this heterogeneous things through a same
platform allows you to do that stuff so
what we have here is a pole with a
camera pointing I don't think the
Raspberry Pi is consumed that much power
because the streetlights themselves are
about 30 watts to 90 watts Raspberry Pi
will be a few watts you know so it's not
going to be much the cameras with
[Music]
Chicago so what's the experience
I think there's not much experience
frankly speaking so in fact this would
probably will I cannot go ahead and see
is it even worth putting these computes
in every poll I think some of that we
have to learn as you go forward so we
are not there yeah yeah I agree with you
yeah in fact we have had some discussion
with the area of things people and so on
and that was we wanted to use that but
then we realize it's too expensive for
us what they have right now so yeah so
anyway so this particular you have
probably seen this video cells just move
on all this is saying it's just people
detector which turns on the street right
so it's a very simple thing we are
actually doing this setting this test
testbed in Electronic City they have
been kind of very willing to work with
us so there is a fiber loop out here
these this in this Infosys seven year
Wipro Avenue and this other role and
these stars are the junctions where
there are some cameras which have been
set up and all these data is going into
a micro data center which is set up in
their office so like that there are two
other rings so they're these three rings
which I've been set up now and all the
data is coming in and this left hand
stack which we are developing can be put
out there and we can kind of develop the
stack as we go along with actual data
coming in from these sources of course
they are interested in traffic
management so we want to kind of see if
we can help them with that and hopefully
with this kind of activity we can have a
solid stack which is kind of tested out
and made available to people basically
right now see an electronic City they
have this camera so here then they have
a solid waste management system and they
want to actually they're trying hard to
set up a smart streetlight management
system and parking is something which
they're concerned with parking
management is something they want to
right now these have they are no
infrared sensors these are the standard
cameras but we will put one or two
thermal imagers also n as an experiment
in this desperate to see what we can do
with those yeah this is the network
there's an optical fiber loop which is
based on Japon gigabit passive optical
network each of the poles in electronic
city has this connectivity to the spawn
and then these are there is a low rom
network also to pick up data from some
of the sensors or laura b sensors so
they are also very interested in water
management so smart water management is
another use case for them so we are also
looking at how to create a PA interface
to the network itself so that some of
the things I mentioned about adaptive
QoS and so on can be experimented as
part of this so the application can go
and change the network setting of course
going forward these kinds of interfaces
in the street become interesting to
support autonomous vehicles and also
connected autonomous vehicles so those
you know where you can have these polls
have beacons and embedded sensors that
are set cetera and this is again where H
compute becomes very interesting for low
latency control testing so this is the
different applications it's not video
analytics from a privacy or that
perspective bad weight reduction is more
from a latency perspective and again
this is I think is an open problem
challenge of how do you do this reliable
real-time control especially for mobile
things as things are moving around and
this is where this is also in sync with
the Phi G activity so this kind of a
setup is also you're planning to use it
for to create a Phi Z test fit for that
so I cannot talk about many different
things some of it more research and some
ones kind of more mundane but the thing
is that for the city stack the data
stack the way we are going about it now
is we are kind of forming a consortium
of academia industry consortium with
some companies like Intel Dell VMware
they just Bosch Cisco these are all
interested to be part of this consortium
so now we are working together to
develop the
more detailed specification of this
particular data layer I've also left
others out here so hopefully they'll be
interest from Microsoft to also
participate in this and other companies
as we go forward and the idea is that
that stack which we are seeing the data
layer stack is articulated out reference
implementation is created and made
available it should be open reference
implementation completely open source
technology and hopefully that will and
that gets tested out in the in
electronic city so it's a solid stack
and hopefully that can become the kernel
for all smart city implementations as he
go forward in India so that is the
aspiration so just to summarize you know
that data layer is what we are focusing
on as part of the smart city solution
because that's the key foundational
layer and it's you know it needs to be
open with SDK API and so on and the
reference implementation will be open
source and made available and it should
be looking at the future you know
enabling future applications Mei and
distributed computing in nono and things
like that and it can't be done by one
entity and really needs a consortium
with you know lot of these problems from
the you guys have also figured out but I
think with companies you know they
hesitate to be you know I this is where
the academia kind of comes in it can be
a neutral entity which can help get this
kind of activity going and this would
probably be something unique in India
and this cannot happens routinely in the
West but this would be something
interesting if you can do it in India so
you know so with that I would like to
thank really good team we have in the
Robert Bosch Centre at ISC and also this
members of the India stack consortium
which is kind of evolving and I hope
that some of you can also participate in
that so thank you
[Applause]